lazy ineffective do-nothing democrats
Chuck Schumer Nancy Pelosi are refusing
to even sit down with President Trump
and congressional Republicans to
negotiate a budget so we can avoid a
government shutdown now before heading
to Capitol Hill earlier today to meet
with Republicans about the tax bill
President Trump tweeted quote meeting
with Chuck and Nancy today about keeping
the government open and working the
problem is they want illegal immigrants
flooding into our country unchecked
they're weak on crime and want to
substantially raise taxes I don't see a
deal then in typical liberal predictable
crybaby fashion well Chuck Schumer Nancy
Pelosi they threw a tempter temper
tantrum it rivals a three-year-old
crocodile tears Chuckie Schumer attacked
President Trump during the press
conference he held today what's this mr.
president it's time to stop tweeting and
start leading as long as he remains a
destructive force it would be a waste of
everyone's time to continue working with
someone who clearly has no interest in
coming to an agreement the president
doesn't indicate he's serious we're not
going to sit down just for a photo-op
this is serious stuff serious stuff a
waste of time to meet with the President
to negotiate a stoppage of a government
shutdown well then the president he
responded by talking to the press corps
in front of two empty chairs where
Schumer and Pelosi were supposed to be
sitting look at this Chuck Schumer and
Nancy Pelosi did not show up for a
meeting today I'm not really that
surprised we have a lot of differences
that week on crime then week on illegal
immigration they before this meeting and
before this missile launch they've been
week on military in terms of spending
very
to get familiar they wanted for a lot of
other things but the military is always
secondary to them and the other thing
they want tax increases and we want
major tax decreases so they decided not
to show up they've been all talk and
they've been no action and now it's even
worse now it's not even called can you
think of one thing Nancy Pelosi Chuck
Schumer have done to help since Donald
Trump was elected a Nancy Pelosi tries
to fire back at the president tweeting
out quote at real Donald Trump well he
now knows that his verbal abuse
you're gonna call that verbal abuse will
no longer be tolerated his empty chair
photo-op showed he's more interested in
stunts and in addressing the needs of
the American people poor Ryan and
McConnell relegated to props sad so
Nancy clothes he's actually saying
tonight the President Trump what he did
as a political stunt what about the fact
that she and Schumer what they pulled
today they wouldn't show up to have a
meeting to fund your government that is
the ultimate political stunt president's
responding by tweeting back after North
Korean and their missile launch it's
more important than ever to fund our
government and military Democrats
shouldn't hold troop funding hostage for
amnesty and illegal immigration Iran on
stopping illegal immigration and one big
they can threaten a government shutdown
to get their demands now what's even
more hypocritical is Pelosi and Schumer
want everyone to feel sorry for them
because President Trump hurt their
widdle feelings now Pelosi and Schumer
forgot all about all the horrible things
will remind them tonight that their
fellow Democrats and the media have been
saying about Donald Trump for ten months
and longer you may remember this his
motives and his actions are contemptible
and I will fight every day until he is
impeached
I rise today mr. speaker to call for the
impeachment of the President of the
United States of America the president's
decision to end daca was heartless and
it was brainless we all agree that
President Trump's decision to end daca
is a despicable act of political
cowardice are we getting closer and
closer to the possibility of yet another
impeachment process after watching the
Clinton impeachment I thought I'd never
see another one but I think we're an
impeachment territorially the first time
president Trump did a tweet last night
and it's week this morning not
presidential
the president's fitness for office is
something that is being called into
question I'm very worried about his
fitness yeah really
all those are just examples they're just
a tip of the iceberg when it comes to
Democrats trashing the president they do
it every day they've called him every
name in the book and then some and
Democrats in there on irrational hatred
for the president it's unlike anything
we've ever seen in modern political
history and that's not including the
liberal mainstream media that has been
trying to destroy president from since
he launched this campaign so Chuck
Schumer Nancy Pelosi they can try and
play the victim all they want and act
like petulant little children all they
want in this case but in reality they're
just feigning moral outrage like they
always do now when it comes to
negotiating a budget if Democrats you
want to play games if you're refusing to
even come to the bargaining table then
guess what you'll own the government
shutdown and for what the president said
today it sounds like he is not going to
be backing down to accommodate your
ridiculous demands and he shouldn't back
down Chuck Schumer Nancy Pelosi they're
going to try and pressure Republicans to
go along with every liberal agenda item
from daca on down the American people
don't want it they want a black male
president Trump and the Republicans into
literally breaking their campaign
promises that would be stupid now
Democrats are also going to try and
deploy their government shutdown scare
tactics like they always do the GOP for
once
you shouldn't budge an inch let them own
it the government by the way never
really ends up shutting down despite the
threat the law
Democrats have been telling over the
years guess what if they do have a quote
government shutdown Social Security
checks they still go out the post office
still delivers mail food stamps well
that's not impacted the executive branch
they still operate the judiciary branch
they function Congress they pretty much
go on like nothing happened the only
people that are directly impacted are
non-essential government employees and
guess what they get they get a furlough
which means they end up getting a paid
vacation because historically Congress
has always retro actively paid their
salaries and they got all the free time
off Republicans need to show spine and
backbone for once please and actually
start fighting for the President's
agenda and for the Forgotten men and
women in this country you know the
people that actually voted you into
power and if Chuck Schumer and Nancy
Pelosi they want to go out and cry they
want to suck their thumb in a corner and
so be it the GOP needs to stop folding
under pressure start actually keeping
your promises start leading now the
budget is a great place to start so get
to work now also tonight the US and the
world of facing an escalating threat
from rocket man himself
Kim jong-un after his rogue regime now
carried out what the Pentagon believes
to be a new ICBM test this missile flew
over 600 miles was in the air for almost
50 minutes it flew 2,800 miles into
space which is higher than any previous
launch from North Korea before landing
in the ocean near Japan now japan's
Prime Minister has ordered an emergency
cabinet meeting and says the missile
could have landed in his country's
exclusive economic zone South Korea
responding by holding a National
Security Council meeting and also
conducting a precision strike drill by
firing their own missile into the ocean
as their show of force and Hawaii
tonight or they began testing nuclear
attack warning sirens now it's the first
time that state has done that in nearly
30 years president Trump also weighed in
on what is now a clear and present
danger that is the growing North Korean
threat that took place earlier today
take a look
Sol was launched a little while ago from
North Korea I will only tell you that we
will take care of it we have general
mattis in the room with us and we've had
a long discussion on it it is a
situation that we will handle and
Secretary of Defense General James Mad
Dog Madison rests the situation as well
let's watch a little over two and a half
hours ago North Korea launched an
intercontinental ballistic missile you
know you went higher frankly than any
previous shots they've taken it's a
research and development effort on their
part to continue building ballistic
missiles that could threaten everywhere
in the world basically but the bottom
line is it's a continued effort to build
a threat serve a ballistic missile
threat that endangers world peace
regional peace and certainly the United
States now with North Korea we're
getting to a point I had hope we'd never
reach Pyongyang's dangerous nuclear
ambitions and now progressing at a very
rapid pace and as you just heard
secretary mattis a the missile fire
today went higher than any other
previous test and now can reach any
place in the world that means a North
Korean ICBM could be capable of hitting
the continental United States
destroying major American cities like
New York and Boston Los Angeles Chicago
tens of millions of American lives now
are in danger not to mention the
hundreds of millions that are being
threatened in South Korea and Japan and
Kim jong-un has created a situation that
the United States and the world can no
longer ignore and right now we're
getting to the point where force might
very well be necessary because clearly
this little crackpot dictator Kim
jong-un is not interested in stopping
his missile tests now the way I see it
America in the world have only a few
options going forward none of them good
in order to stop North Korea from
reaching full nuclear program capability
we the next have to destroy the next
North Korean missile test on the launch
pad shoot it out of the air after it's
been fired and if that doesn't stop
North Korea then we could attack and try
destroy the nuclear sites but that
becomes with massive risks and huge
uncertainties what if we're not
successful what we now know is not
working the approach that is taken by
Democrats appeasers like Bill Clinton
and Barack Obama they tried to appease
North Korea it has failed miserably as
appeasement always does and in 1994 the
Clinton administration
remember they tried to bribe Kim
jong-un's father Kim jong-il they gave
North Korea four billion dollars in
energy aid in exchange for a promise
that the rogue regime would freeze and
eventually end their nuclear weapons
program a lot of good that did at that
time Clinton went on national TV
bragging about how his bribery worked
and was such a good deal for you it's
good to deal for American people
remember this this is a good deal for
the United States North Korea will
freeze and then dismantle its nuclear
program South Korea and our other allies
will be better protected the entire
world will be safer as we slow the
spread of nuclear weapons South Korea
with support from Japan and other
nations will bear most of the cost of
providing North Korea with fuel to make
up for the nuclear energy it is losing
and they will pay for an alternative
power system for North Korea that will
allow them to produce electricity while
making it much harder for them to
produce nuclear weapons the United
States and international inspectors will
carefully monitor North Korea to make
sure it keeps its commitments only as it
does so will North Korea fully join the
community of nations none of what you
heard it was true it all turned out it
was a terrible deal with North Korea
your tax dollars at work Bill Clinton
completely wrong and it has now led us
to where we are tonight in this
situation we now find ourselves in
Democrats and the left I'll never get it
obsessed with sucking up to murderous
radical dictators and despots they're
more willing to bend over backwards for
people like Kim jong-un and his father
Kim jong-il but guess what history has
proven over and over again it never
works we saw what happened with Neville
Chamberlain and Adolf Hitler his
appeasement policies well that cleared
the way for Germany's invasion of Europe
Clinton throwing billions at North Korea
led us to where we are today and if
anything happens the blame will fall
right at the feet of Bill Clinton and
his stupidity and his ignorant and his
belief in a fantasy that that's putz
listen to him and by the way this led to
the situation and the foundation of
where we are today and the same goes
with President Obama's disasters nuclear
deal with Iran this will come back to
bite us Obama giving Tehran and the
mullahs upwards of a hundred and fifty
billion dollars Obama allowing that
rogue regime to keep spinning their
nuclear centrifuges and put them on a
path towards getting a nuclear weapon as
a result Obama now owns that terrible
decision to appease a country that
routinely calls for death to America
wants to wipe Israel off the map and
before we bring in Kellyanne Conway for
reaction to other breaking news stories
to tell you about one catherine herridge
is out with an explosive report take a
look at the headline blowback Clinton
campaign planned to fire me over email
probe Obama Intel watchdog says and the
former intelligence community Inspector
General who played a key role in the
Clinton email investigation is now
saying that Clinton allies literally
threatened him his family and his
staffers and the Clinton campaign also
made it be known that this Inspector
General would be fired if Hillary in
fact won in 2016 also finally tonight a
major development in the uranium one
scandal the hills John Solomon out with
a brand new report here's that headline
Clinton's understated support from firm
hired by Russian nuclear company
according to Solomon he'll join us later
the Clinton Foundation may have
significantly underreported the
donations they got from a company with
deep ties to Russia more later but first
joining us